also fragen über fragen sprechen wir
darüber mit kolonisten hans ulrich
jörges der jetzt hier bei uns im studio
ist vor weihnachten bild zeigt holwijn
schön hast du hier bist aber wir haben
viele fragen wahrscheinlich ganze auch
nicht alle beantworten wenn die
verwirkung jetzt kurz vor weihnachten
was darf ich überhaupt darf ich in die
kneipen oder trinken gehen und wie lange
überhaupt wenn wir die schwiegermutter
zu viel wird die können ja auch
vermutlich alle nicht anfangen ich
glaube auch dass die menschen sich
abgewöhnt haben auf die details zu
schauen die bewegen sich nach gefühl
durch die gesellschaft und nach eigener
verantwortung das ist auch genau richtig
so und dass nun die diversen
landesregierung ganz unterschiedliche
regelungen getroffen haben ist ziemlich
wurscht weil das interessiert mich in
kiel nicht was in
münchen gilt sondern in kiel
interessiert was in kiel gilt und das
ist im prinzip auch richtig also viel
interessanter ist die frage was hat sich
eigentlich grundsätzlich an der korona
politik geändert unter der neuen
regierung und da finde ich schon
auffällig und auch ein bisschen
ermutigend dass diese neue regierung so
ähnlich sieht der alten in der
kurzatmigkeit der politik ist doch in
einem wesentlich widerspricht sie ist
nämlich nicht mehr hysterisch unterwegs
sie befeuert die angst nicht mehr sie
hat sich offenbar vorgenommen beruhigend
auf die öffentlichkeit zu wirken also
olaf scholz tritt ganz anders auf als
angela merkel im kanzleramt sitzt ein
anderes team auch herr braun tritt nicht
mehr aufs gas merkt man deutlich die
wollen erst mal gucken was sich
überhaupt an an omikron aufbaut wie
gefährlich das ist aus england gibt es
ja ja beruhigende nachrichten dass zwar
diese infektion wahnsinnig schnell um
sich greift aber nicht so viele leute in
die krankenhäuser schickt also weniger
gefährlich ist weil man hoffen dass es
dabei bleibt und wir haben also eine
etwas
zurückhaltender auftreten der regierung
die das volk er beruhigt als es noch
weiter in unruhe zu versetzen
diese regierung ist offenbar
entschlossen so weit sie es kann einen
bundesweiten lockdown zu verhindern ich
sehe nicht vorläufig da müsste schon
viel passieren und
wir haben ja auch eine eigentümliche
umkehrung der rollen die karl lauterbach
karl lauterbach der immer als chef
apokalyptiker durch die landschaft
gelaufen ist und immer fortgeschrieben
hat ist jetzt ein verantwortungsvoller
ruhiger auch beruhigende
gesundheitsminister ich glaube dass olaf
scholz mit ihm bevor er das amt
angetreten hat ein unter vier augen ein
paar worte gewechselt hat was er von ihm
erwartet nämlich genau das und wir haben
jetzt einen anderen menschen den ich
beobachte mit großer großem interesse
der seine rolle einnimmt als
apokalyptiker da sind das ist ja noch
stammen janosch dahmen ist der
gesundheitspolitiker der grünen achten
sie mal darauf der ist jetzt ständig
unterwegs und waren von diesem und jenem
so hat man früher
karl lauterbach erlebt und da sie den
namen wie schon erwähnt haben ich bin
oder sommer mal etwas vorsichtiger mein
eindruck war dass lothar wieler
entlassen werden wollte das war eine
solch fulminante provokation der neuen
regierung und seines neuen ministers
dass er eigentlich nicht im amt bleiben
konnte aber natürlich konnte sich karl
lauterbach nicht leisten ihn jetzt vor
den feiertagen vor der anlaufenden
omikron welle an die luft zu setzen
solange er keinen nachfolger hat ich
habe zweifel daran ob dieses
angeschlagener verhältnis wieder zu
kitten ist ich gehe mal davon aus dass
herr lauterbach sich schon gedanken
macht wenn er an seine stelle berufen
könnte und mein eindruck von villa war
das ist ein beamter der der unter keinen
umständen provokativ der regierung in
den arm fallen darf das ist eine
nachgeordnete behörde
ich glaube dass wir entweder keine lust
mehr hatten mit dieser ampel koalition
zu arbeiten oder aber auch ein ganz
einfach erschöpft ist durch zwei jahre
verschleiß in dieser behörde im rk ii
und nach meinem eindruck ist beim rk ii
ja nichts besser geworden in diesen zwei
jahren die daten die die sammeln sind
immer zu spät hinken ein paar tage
hinterher mindestens ein paar tage geben
der politik also aktuell nicht den
richtigen finger zeigen was sie zu tun
hat die gesundheitsämter sind nicht
richtig eingebunden
da wird nach gefaxt wird tage später
werden noch daten ausgebessert da fragt
man sich leute was habt ihr in den
letzten zwei jahren gemacht also für
mich wäre es kein schaden wenn not abila
gehen würde und ein anderer oder eine
andere an seine stelle treten würde karl
lauterbach müsste sie oder ihn suchen
karl lauterbach der von dir gelobt wird
und der auch jetzt wird von mir gelobt
und auch
sehr erstaunliche entwicklung nach
angela merkel inzwischen der beliebteste
politiker in deutschland ist und es ist
nur noch ein zehntel das ihm von ihr
trennt er könnte sie dann überholen wenn
angela merkel noch ein bisschen mehr in
vergessenheit gerät und da ist karl
lauterbach der beliebteste politiker in
deutschland herr uhr weihnachten vielen
dank oli jou weihnacht an euch